Speaker 1: Let's go next to
S.D. from Dallas, Texas. S.D.,
you're on the air.
Speaker 3: I even.
What is your take on so the states are now making
the new maps for all the legislative districts,
and I want to know what's your take so far
on the gerrymandering for this coming decade?
Speaker 1: I've not read that much about it other
than there are some interesting districts that
could just be eliminated, like, for example,
Lauren Bowerbirds district. I guess if the
proposed map is accepted, she may just
not have a district anymore. I've not
you know, one of the things I'm trying to do is
when there is like maybes, let's wait and see
if something is happening, unless there's really
something specific that could be done to change
the course. And with a lot of the gerrymandering
and district drawing that's being proposed,
we're still waiting to see like what are the
final submissions and are they even really
going to be accepted? So I don't know. I mean,
what's your take? Is it are there particularly
egregious examples that we should be looking at?
Speaker 3: Oh, yes. Oh, yes. Yeah. You can look
at states like like Texas and Ohio. It is like
absolutely egregious. The the state legislature
are absolutely certain, the mid-February. But I
guess I was really more looking into is knowing
that the gerrymandering is going to be pretty
egregious across a lot of these red states.
Is it worth dropping the principle of
no gerrymandering in blue states and
just fighting fire with fire? At this point?
Speaker 1: I know this is always the thing,
which is if the Republicans are just going
to keep doing it in the states they control,
isn't it unilateral disarmament to say, all right,
well, we'll draw them fairly in the blue states
and then they'll draw them completely unfairly
in the red states? I think on this, for as long
as these are the rules, Democrats have no choice
but to use the system to their advantage when they
can, because otherwise we will never even get the
opportunity to change how this is done. But the
goal has to be to change the system. And then, of
course, you get to this question of our people who
got in because of the system. We have really
going to be motivated to change it. And that's
a very legitimate question, which we addressed,
I think it was last week on the show. But no,
I mean, listen, if if Democrats just say let's
drop perfectly square districts everywhere and
do everything perfectly and then Republicans keep
doing like they're Dan Crenshaw district, it's one
of the most egregious examples of Republicans do,
then it just further makes it so that Democrats
will never actually be in power and able to
really deal with this issue. So it's unfortunate,
but it is what it is.
Speaker 3:
Absolutely right on, David, thank you very much.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you so much for
the call. Very important question. Very
important question. There are areas where
we say we're not going to stoop to that
level because then we are as bad as them.
When this is the system, you know, it's sort
of like saying I won't even accept political
donations. OK, well then we just lose, right?
OK, we have to work to we have to do campaign
finance reform, but we will never even get that
opportunity if everybody on the left is like,
I won't even do campaign donations. Now, the
person who raises more money tends to win. And
it's just an unfortunate reality. Let's go next to
let's go to Browdy from Dallas. We haven't heard
from Brody for a while. What's going on there?
Speaker 3: Hey, what's up, David? I'm
doing pretty well, how are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 3: Thanks. I wasn't expecting you to call
me so quickly. It's good to speak to you again. I
had a few questions regarding the
infrastructure bill and the midterms,
as you probably know. And as you reported on an
hour where the Progressive Caucus are seeking
to basically get the deal that was agreed to
previously, which is the infrastructure and the,
you know, both bills moving at the same time. Do
you anticipate if it fails, meaning if both bills
are not passed the same time, that the blame is
going to be placed on the progressives solely?
Do you think it will be blamed on the Democrats?
What do you think the fallout will be and what
do you anticipate to happen with that bill?
Speaker 1: It really depends on the media
coverage between now and whenever that ultimately
happens. I think that all of the usual suspects
are going to do all of the usual blaming. So
Republicans will blame Democrats for crazy bills,
too much spending, blah, blah, blah. Centrist
Democrats will try to blame the progressive wing.
The progressive wing will say centrist Democrats
trying to make nice with Republicans is what
ultimately so all the usual suspects will do,
all the normal blaming. What narrative succeeds
is ultimately going to depend
on corporate media coverage. And
and that that is unfortunately always the case.
But I just think there's no way to know right now.
Everybody will attempt to blame exactly who
we would expect, but whether that will stick
in the minds of people as this is who is to
blame. I just don't know yet. It's sort of
like when we have this debt ceiling issue and
sometimes the public blames Democrats more,
sometimes they blame Republicans more.
Typically, it's just the fault of Republicans.
But the media coverage of it is often what
determines who gets the blame politically. It's
an unfortunate reality, but it is the reality.
Speaker 3: And then one last quick question. Do
you think that there will be any fallout from
the debt ceiling argument and posturing with
regards to maybe increasing support for
changing or carving out the filibuster?
Or do you think it will remain the same?
Speaker 1: I'm not sure I know what you
mean. Whether whether the filibuster
argument will be affected, I guess,
by whether these bills pass, I'm sorry.
Speaker 3: On a separate track with McConnell
posturing over the debt ceiling shutting down the
government, will that put any impetus and a change
on how folks feel about the filibuster?
Speaker 1: Sadly, I don't think so.
I mean, I don't know. I guess to
just keep it short. I don't think so.
Speaker 3: Well, thanks, David. Good talk to you.
Speaker 1: Pleasure. All right. There is
there's Brody from Dallas.